où je suis crevée moi je suis crevé on
sait bien c'est bon je suis au bout du
rouleau simple bout du rouleau
parce que les gens ne se rendent pas
compte déjà 10 employé municipal
employées municipales il est facile
il sera de pâques qui se disait papier
c'est vite vu ses vitres avancé non je
suis désolé moi un papier c'est vite vu
mais c'est pas vite ramasser des prenons
un exemple tout bête iem papier là mes
yeux le voir qu'est ce qui se passe vite
mes yeux passer l'information dans mon
cerveau et là mon cerveau feignant
s'adresse aux tiennent à parce qu'ils se
connaissent mais bien sûr qu'ils se
connaissent et là qu'est ce qui se passe
est au cerveau gérer mon cerveau pas qu
ils ne cherchent même plus compte que
lui pour faire le boulot
nantes à l'âge tu arrêtes de suite à
gagner du temps non chez toi c'est le
terminus ya pas plus qu'aux tout le
monde descend non là ton cerveau passer
l'information datée doit de saisir le
papier et de le mettre dans le sac
plastique
mon dieu pourvu que les doigts soit lent
mais bien sûr qu'ils sont là les droits
honneur de les y sommes tous les soirs
là les droits il faut voir comme ils
sont payés à la fin du moins trois mois
c'est bien simple qu'elle joue à ma
feuille de paie j'ai plutôt envie de me
[ __ ] en grève qui avaient d'ailleurs
c'est ce que je fais tient genou font
grève allez ciao
si on m'appelle h au bistrot je me
demande si après une embrouille chaque
fois il me fait le coup
et pourtant soyez lucide tout le monde
personne ne considère mais soyez lucides
ne sommes nous pas nous les blouses
bleues les bases d'une pyramide dont le
maire est le sommet regardez il est 5
heures du matin et c'est l'avant garde
de notre armée qui se met à travailler
on la voit elle se meut dans l'aube et
airs et les bras de sacs bleus chargés
aux 10 heures viennent de sonner et
c'est toute notre armée qui se met à
travailler on met sa blouse
on réfléchit et midi viennent de sonner
aux trois heures déjà l'heure de
reprendre et de trois heures à 5 heures
il n'y a qu'une heure si l'on compte la
mise en train alors c'est toute notre
armée qui arras et dépose ses armes
devant son casier on ce n'est pas le
courage c'est la force qui lui manquent
à l'idée d'un week-end prolongé qui va
casser le rythme de l'année
certes vous pouvez ricaner je sais que
nous ne sommes pas considérés
mais si vous saviez combien c'est dur de
savoir que l'on est rien si vous saviez
comme je m'en veux de n'être rien mon
dieu
je m'en veux mais je m'en veux de n'être
rien mon dieu que je m'en veux mais je
m'en veux aux colères toi et sois fier
d'être municipal un super municipal
oui c'est comme ça qu'on m'appelle puis
je t'appelais super muni je vois que tu
es observateurs oui mais appelle moi
tout simplement muni oui 10 min whee
emmène moi oui je tombe bien je t'emmène
jetons mais je suis m'emmène oui je
tombais
mais où m'emmène tu vers un monde
meilleur mais qu'at-il de meilleur ce
monde magique des camions bennes
j'imaginais des camions bennes ont dit
parler célimène décès libel des célimène
des séminaires oui oui déçu l'image de
soliman weeds et célimène
et dans ce monde meilleur où il y aurait
des cinémas n'y aura-t-il encore
déballés
il m'a dessiné par jean paul gaultier
jean gauthier oui jean gauthier tu
m'emmènes oui
partons tous pour ce monde meilleur pour
ce monde meilleur
[Musique]